who has more cred than you living after
being shot nine [ __ ] times i never i
well i don't know what the criterias are
for street credibility that's if there's
a
if there's something that creates more
merit for you i i looked at that
experience as something that was
unfortunate that i had to excuse it i
forget why the guy shook you nine times
was it drugs or something it was paid to
do it he was paid to do it yeah who
would want to shoot you targeted you're
such a good guy this is my past
it was a drug thing like a business
thing
karma karma explain to me again why this
guy was hired to shoot you nine times
well you just paid cause someone you
know felt like that uh
i would potentially do something to them
if they kept going in the direction that
they were going you aren't tough
[ __ ]
what are you talking about
the fact that somebody put out a hit on
him because he was gonna [ __ ] somebody
up what kind of [ __ ] is that that's
crazy what is this all over i don't know
it's well it's difficult to explain
because when you're not actually an
environmental involvement it's just like
you can't explain it we'll see if we can
follow it
what happened what had you so tough you
were pissed off at someone and you were
going after them what were you pissed
off about now he was just having
differences oh like over what a woman no
one's going back and forth like a guy
got robbed in an actual neighborhood
and he accused you of robbing you just
seen me
communicating with someone who actually
robbed him that's the robber and he
misinterpreted
the conversation because he see me
laughing and i was talking but he didn't
know i grew up with the guy you're
talking to a guy who you don't even know
[ __ ] up this other guy yeah and now
all of a sudden they think you're in
cahoots with this guy yeah cause you see
you laughing and talking they figure
you're laughing and talking about them
pain wise how bad is it to get shot in
the face like i mean
probably
i don't know how to describe that
outside of uh
is it a 10 on the pain scale
it's like it's not really like because
it's not as painful as
having to visit
the dentist repeatedly for root canal
really
do you think you're dead at that point
when you get take nine bullets do you go
oh this is it i'm checking out
well you know it's you it's a
life-threatening situation it's just not
i've seen people going to the hospital
and the circumstances
were way
less
intense and not come out yeah it's a
miracle you live did you think you were
like like jesus had like saved you or
something like did you have a religion
you have those moments where you you get
a little closer connection to your
higher power because you kind of don't
have an answer where were all these
bullets because if you're shot nine
times yeah and you live it probably
didn't hit anything important meanwhile
how lame is this guy who [ __ ] is
important robin everything's important
but 50 how how lame is just you and one
of your unimportant areas robert
yeah right what's an unimportant area
you're right
oh yeah he shot you in unimportant areas
it's amazing your face isn't scarred
from getting shot in the face right you
got the little dimple oh is that what
it's from wow look at that